all right we're here uh over time
questions on the Internet's what does
the panel think of the poll that for the
first time shows that a majority of
Americans favor the legalization of
marijuana do you think of that run your
about the Constitution and democracy you
just said that if the amount if the
majority wanted shouldn't have happened
no I think there's a reason why so we
should all break the law there's a
reason why narco they're saying change
the way yeah yeah finally James you know
if people want to change the law and
they want to petition the government did
you ever get home no no did you invest
is the problem this is the problem we
will fix this in about 10 days
oh here's a good one for you this says
Bob Poole are asked why are there so few
good Republican comedians now is it
because I know you are a very good
comedian you've got voted like the
funniest wittiest guy in DC every year
and you actually plug your standup dates
thank you why are there so few
Republican comedians and it's true there
are few I don't know it's a good
question we do get both Republicans and
Democrats congressmen and Senators to
perform in DC but Kucinich is the best
he's a ventriloquist Democrat from
Cleveland he's a Republican
Ed Gillespie is also a very talented
ventriloquist the two of them did a
routine just couple years ago that's
good and what what do you what kind of
material do you do who do you make fun
of it like like it's so easy to be a
liberal comedian because you can make
fun of people like Michele Bachmann and
Rick Perry and people who say dumb
things just actually I tend to do more
family humor rather than political humor
I mean some political stuff well see I
mean I think that answers our question
it's because there's less material on
the other side there's less it's
shooting about for me because honestly
come on if we can have ideological
differences but the people who are just
knowledge challenged are almost always
on the right 57 states exactly 50 57
States
seven-stage okay but but when Herman
Cain talks about abortion and and says
it's absolutely should be illegal and
it's up to the family he means it
Obama just misspoke a word Oh miss Obama
misspoke award there he must do you
think Obama really thinks there were 57
all I know is that's what he said once
and you're still talking about Obama
thinks there are 50s no he doesn't I
don't think he thinks they're 57 Stacy I
do think that when Republicans misspeak
you guys jump in Republicans but the
president always gets a free but they
don't misspeak they miss thing
[Applause]
Oh so again don't like so he doesn't
miss pink is that Republicans miss think
but the president says oh the stimulus
bill is gonna create all these jobs oh
here's my program for America that's
gonna change employment oh but those
aren't misspoken statements they didn't
come out to be true well now you're to
borrow a Herman Cain phrase comparing
apples and I think I think you speaking
the truth when you look at Mark Twain
Richard Pryor Lenny Bruce and others
they're wrestling with radical
incongruity that has deep suspicions of
dogma if your right-wing tied to Dogma
is gonna be difficult to be a great
comic actually Lenny Britain Lenny
Bruce's best line for criticisms of
socialism I mean the treaty does make
him clean he would be critical he's
critical of himself he's critical across
the board he languished got a lot left I
don't know he was progressive he well he
wasn't a follower of tax reform the
joopa he won't quite good on free-market
issues where we libertarian yeah I'm a
libertarian but not a follower of your
organization oh you're part of the tax
increasing wing of the libertarian
movement well no it depends on which
groups being taxed okay we're dumb
always you know gets me going because I
found that in all the wars I've been in
the greatest killer on the planet is TB
and I don't mean to Burke you're lysis I
mean true believers
I mean inclined yeah that's true
how does Grover feel about the fact that
there are rich people who feel that they
don't pay enough taxes it was one thing
I wanted to get through and I ran out of
I sent a letter to mr. Buffett and
showed him how you can write a check to
the federal government you don't have to
involve anybody else and there's
actually a new law that's introduced no
there's a new law that's been introduced
called the tax me more line that Steve
Scalise congressman from Louisiana has
so that Warren Buffett can go in and
fill in Soren Buffett this week it came
out that a majority of millionaires in
this country think they should pay more
taxes and you know the answer isn't for
them to just write a check the answer is
to come on my mom's has to be a law
Maimonides had the great 8 different
levels of charity the ninth down below
the mall Maimonides the Talmudic scholar
from Spain I'd love to give something
but I I'll wait till the law gets passed
below the other I think by the bills
point was there always the question of
interest sometimes it's a matter of
principle and there are rich people who
have principles there more justice it's
not just a matter of them individually
giving
[Applause]
would you trust you know once I want to
be on the cane camp I want to light up
[Laughter]
this shell-shocked you know it's I have
a mental disorder that's but you know
what your but we still love you the
self-diagnose would you trust a Mormon
president yes would you trust a Mormon
less than say a Protestant or Catholic
president or would you put them all in
the same category you don't know which
one depends on which well I think what
they're saying is that you know more
believers
yeah no but they're prophetic Mormons or
reactionary Mormons I mean you know in
residence is as evil as any other
prejudice it depends on which Mormon it
is because know what Christian which 80
which agnostic which I'm actually very
cool with the Mormons because they have
shown their ability especially Mitt
Romney to do a 180 on anything they
believe excuse me this is a religion
that was founded on the idea of polygamy
but when they wanted to be a state Utah
in 1890 they went [ __ ] it it came from
God it's direct from heaven it's written
inside was a religion that wouldn't
ordain black people until what was it
1970 oh yes America go beyond Mormonism
in terms of that yeah but the thing is
both but also was devil's done at
gunpoint
I mean Mormons have been a persecuted
people who were run from state to state
to state to state with the federal ended
up in Utah they started
because their leader was a [ __ ] crook
[Music]
[Laughter]
Joseph Smith he was the Bernie Madoff of
his day it would be as if grown yes he
was convicted for fraud and all that
sort of thing prior to his finding the
gold tablets he had a scam he would tell
people that if you paid him he could see
through the stones and discover where
the gold was on your land okay that's
why they kept chasing him because he
kept robbing people it was if it wasn't
as if Bernie Madoff did that and we got
chased the Utah and then created Murdoch
Madoff State but you don't have a Madoff
community that was willing to follow him
to Utah because of the leadership he was
exercising Joseph Smith was involved in
a whole host of claims that we can call
into question but here with his
community he's struggling with them and
he's willing to be persecuted and he was
know he really was a straight-up con man
he was a straight-up con man are you
defending this con man because there's a
common element to every tradition that I
know of
but is not reducible gift and it's not
like Jesus had lungs in ski you know
it's not like Buddha was selling
timeshares I mean
[Applause]